or russia should be made to pay post-war
reparations to ukraine once the conflict
between the two has ended the ukrainian
finance minister has said sergey
machenko told me in an exclusive tv
interview yesterday and estimated that
the total cost for reconstruction could
run into hundreds of billions of dollars
when i spoke to him from kiev i asked
for his thoughts of prime minister boris
johnson visiting the city at the weekend
and what more foreign governments can do
it was a very
nice visit of your prime minister i want
to express my personal gratitude to the
prime minister of the united kingdom
boris johnson and his leadership in
supporting ukraine i've had pleasure to
attend meetings with him recently in
kiev where he had announced additional
500 million us dollars of financial
support we also thankful for uk for
participating in trust fund created
under the world bank so i believe that
that kind of leadership is that we need
right now from all around the world to
different other countries so here's a
very good example what's uh
very
what
leader of today's society should be like
boris johnson
but are you looking necessarily for more
financial assistance on a on a bilateral
basis from countries or are you
preferring it to come from the world
bank and the imf
you know now we
created several tools which can help
different countries to support ukraine
first of all it's a multi-donor trust
fund
created by world bank another instrument
is an administrative account of imf
which can help different countries to
to through to channel their
money or donor loans to to the ukraine
so we are negotiated bilateral with
different countries and we're expecting
to
to receive the support in the nearest
future
and presumably it would also be a great
help if the west were to stop buying
russian oil and gas
yes it will help us and
we
do
as possible uh to to deal with different
countries to show that
sanction is not enough and we need much
more because we still in a war with
russia
and to win this war this we should have
additional pressure on them because
if they receive dollars to support their
military
it means that they next time be in
ukraine so that's why
embargo on oil and gas
from russia will be next step for for
johnson and we uh eager to receive this
sanction from
eu and different other countries
eu countries such as germany argue that
it's impossible for them to stop buying
russian gas because it would put their
country into a recession what would you
say to them
you know
please look at uh
ukraine and this particular momentum
time
the russians kills our peoples destroy
our infrastructure
destroy our economy and it's not just a
question of we will win it's a question
what time takes us to win this war and
uh for all who
wants to support and to deal with russia
we want to show that
it's it it's our time it's our people
who are killed and that's why your
decision it's a question of
how
how much people we
can be able to save
using
your
decisions
so would you say then a recession in
parts of the eu would be a small price
to pay if it
stopped russia's war on ukraine
i think it it it is so it uh
it
of course uh i don't expect that the
great recession was in eu but
as a preliminary estimation of eu it
means that they can
lose
partly
maybe
lower than one percent of their
predicted
privo gdp growth so
if it will be
one percent one percent and five for us
it's a uh
good signal that they can manage to do
so
but for us it's a
great damage and we can't expect any
other
ideas how to support ukraine obviously
hundreds of millions of people around
the world depend on rush on ukrainian
grain exports there's a big sowing
season coming up next month
how worried are you that that will not
be able to go ahead
you know that
we try to do our best to
to safeguard necessary conditions for
our farmers to sowing campaign
we provided them zero percent loans
to
find necessary money for them to
per petrol for other
commodities or
chemicals to start the solving campaign
and as of now we see possible to sow 80
percent of
length
in comparison with previous years it
will be a
good result if you if you will do so
is it too early to start thinking about
post-war reconstruction in ukraine
i don't think it's uh
early or not it's a question of finding
the right mechanism safeguarding
necessary amount of
funds which can be used
or could be useful like uh russian
frozen
assets etc and collected for ukraine
especially and
which we can use after the war of course
to start uh doing reconstruction after
the war we should be able to create
these funds right now
and
to start this process right now
how much money do you think ukraine will
need
it's a hundreds of billions of dollars
because uh
just our infrastructure critical
infrastructure cost us 120 billion
dollar which we which were damaged by
war
and uh if we had uh social and military
military infrastructure it could be more
than 500 billion dollars i mean there's
been talk of uh
a marshall plan for ukraine if you like
is is that the sort of thing that you
could conceive happening
yes it's possible when i mentioned that
we should create such a fund or vehicle
how to support ukraine i mentioned that
it was a experience of post-war
europe
how they
reconstruct how they create necessary
incentives to rebuild their economy it
should be something like that martial
plan for ukraine we name it u-24
recovery plan
and it could be possible to start this
plan just after the war
and should russia be made to pay
reparations to ukraine after the war
yes we expect so and it's not just only
frozen asset of banks of russia it's
frozen assets from business oligarchs
from russia it also abused other
taxes additional taxes on russia oil and
gas which can be directed towards
ukraine or other mechanism of
repatriation because uh
because of their decision they should
pay for that and doing war in ukraine
it's uh
their decision that's why
they should pay for this decision after
the war
and how should those reparations be
enforced you'd expect the international
community to do that
it's a partly political decision it
could be made through different
political decisions from different
countries or and uh on other hand it's a
international judicial
judicial process
which can be moved
with uh
with a based on
existing instrument to suit russia of
their assets
and to collect necessary amount of money
towards this fund of a creation ukraine